i think that if ukraine were to be
crushed or forced into a bad peace the
consequences for freedom around the
world would be appalling and that view
is shared by everyone in nato so let's
be absolutely clear
the best way for us to win the argument
around the world about our values what
we stand for about our opposition to the
use of force to change boundaries about
the the primacy of of international law
the best way to win that argument is for
the ukrainians to win
and for putin to fail in ukraine
and that's why i'm pleased today that
we've announced another billion pounds
worth of military support
and if you wanted evidence of the
amazing ability of the ukrainians to
fight back to overcome adversity and to
repel the russians and look uh what has
happened uh just uh today on snake
island where again russia has had to
cede ground
in the end it will prove impossible for
putin to hold down a country that will
not accept his rule
this has been a crucial summit in that
we are resolved not just to support
ukraine but we've agreed a new strategic
concept where
we're moving uh additionally beyond the
doctrine of tripwire deterrence uh on
nato's eastern flank to a new approach
of defence deterrence by denial
and
countries around the table are also
recognizing that they need to spend more
and in our case that means meeting and
being prepared to exceed the target we
set for ourselves a decade
ago of everybody spending two percent of
gdp on defense
the goals that were then set for a very
different era and what we're saying is
that we want yens uh stoltenberg the
secretary general uh to start work on
that new target now and and he's agreed
to do that
we need to invest for the long term in
vital capabilities like future combat
air while simultaneously adapting to a
more dangerous and more competitive
world and the logical conclusion of the
investments on which uh we propose to
embark uh of these decisions is that we
will reach 2.5 percent of gdp on defense
by the end of the decade
i want to say
a big thank you to our to our spanish
hosts i think they've done an amazing
job i want to thank against stoltenberg
and my views at the end of this madrid
summit the the nato alliance is plainly
in robust health
and getting stronger with new members
and a renewed purpose we can see that
our work is cut out and we can see that
there are billions of people around the
world swing voters who need to hear and
to understand our arguments
but we have a huge advantage of knowing
what we want in believing in our ideas
and having the means to do what we want
to do
and above all
we are united and if history is any
guide then i believe that this great
alliance will again be successful
thank you all very much and i'd like to
go to the media where we i think we've
got question first from chris mason the
bbc
thank you chris mason bbc news prime
minister what is the overall objective
of the uk's health and strategy for
ukraine is it unequivocally getting the
russians out restoring ukraine's borders
to how they were before the war
and if i may you've been out of the
country for eight days are you actually
looking forward to returning home given
the ongoing speculation about your own
future
on the second point yes i can't tell you
how much i'm looking forward to not that
i've been wonderful being here in madrid
one uh as india's i enjoyed being in
kigali and and germany uh but uh you
know uh there's no place like home so
i'm i'm
i'm keen to get back uh on on your point
about where we're trying to what the
what the
um
what's the what's the guy we can't be
more ukrainian than the ukrainians
everybody understands that it's for it's
for vladimir zolensky uh his uh people
to uh to decide what they what they want
to do whether whether they want to uh to
cut a deal with uh with russia to make
some kind of piece of course that's
entirely a matter
for them though i noticed that after the
attack on the shopping center i think i
saw a poll saying that 89
of uh ukrainians would under no
circumstances uh contemplate a
a a a land for peace deal so you know i
can see that the difficulties in in
ukraine our job is simply to vindicate
the principle to stand up for the
principle of the right of the ukrainians
to protect themselves that's what we're
doing that's what everybody in the
alliances is doing
and uh we want to give them the means to
repel the uh the russians to expel uh
the russians from the territory that
they have occupied because that is the
right thing under international law and
as everybody has said uh we want at the
very least to put zolensky in the best
possible position uh he could be in if
and when he decides that there is
anything to talk about but at the moment
let's be absolutely clear
there doesn't seem to be anything to
talk about because it's not only that
the ukrainian people would find it very
difficult to do a deal
putin isn't even offering a deal he
isn't even offering a deal
under those circumstances it is only
logical and a right to continue to
support ukraine in the way that we are
and indeed to continue to to intensify
that military support because i think
that they do have the potential to turn
this round uh we've seen what ukraine
can do
uh to drive the russians back we've seen
what they did around kiev around kharkiv
now on snake island i think the right
thing for us is to keep going on the
course that nato has set out no matter
how difficult uh it
but that's what this summit has
certainly agreed
romney weeks of itv
i'll shout too
prime minister the american assessment
is that the war in ukraine could drop
grind on for an extended period of time
do you really think you've won the
argument amongst fellow leaders to
support ukraine to the bitter end and do
you think you can sustain an appetite
for that back home
so romney i think
it's a
i think the argument here at nato the
argument at g7
is very very clear and everybody i think
is there's a great deal of unity
uh around this around this table
everybody can see the point of principle
but everybody can see the practical
consequences for the world it would be
disastrous if uh if putin were to
succeed in ukraine so there's a the the
strong unanimity here
for a very long time you've talked a lot
about how this is going to abate fairly
soon are you at risk of being complacent
about inflation do you need to do more
to deal with the fallout of this war so
i i think we we have to recognize that
the uk is exposed to two particular
types of of issue we've got
very very low unemployment which means
we have by comparison with uh a lot of
other countries around the table which
we've got a very very tight labor market
uh which which has a an inflationary
pressure and our the balance of our
energy mixes is also uh difficult at the
moment
we have to deal with uh those issues
you've got to deal with a lot of the
underlying causes of of cost
pressures for for people for businesses
for the whole country and so
we've got to help people in the with the
costs with the 1200 pounds all the other
help that we're we're giving help
helping people with
trying to
to get through the price spike but
you've also got to try to look at the
root causes and i think there are things
going on in the uk economy whether it's
in the the housing market or the energy
market uh
our transport systems which are driving
the way government spends money uh which
are driving unnecessary cost pressures
for people in our country and those are
the things that we need to to fix as
part of our plan for a stronger economy
so i i i christianize you you're
basically in no way minimize the the
importance of this but nor do i minimize
this is a big chance for us now to do
things differently and do things better
and
create foundations for for much stronger
economy